would say all Society very much is about
individualism now because like
capitalism is fundamentally based on
individualism and so therefore you you
feed into your own values now so now
when you're in a marriage you think what
do I want not what my husband or partner
wants right now
problematic because it makes it more
competitive the market and it makes your
dating life
I think it's a problem because it's not
supposed to be about you it's supposed
to be about the family exactly it's
supposed to be especially the kid like I
just think as a mother you should want
your kids to be happy Above All Else But
if you're starting your relationship
surely that's gonna transpire us your
kids I know but I'm saying I'm saying
I'm saying like why can't you just put
that aside but let's say raise your kid
raise your kids and then after that you
could focus on your happiness
some of the practice is that as a child
you learn by example and if you watch
your parents argue or you watch your mum
constantly compromise her values and say
fine learn not to argue yeah but the
fact is not to get learn to get along